[Musique]
on a le droit d'aller voir avec la clé
au sein de la clé à baie comeau
l'essentiel c'est qu'ils puissent
rentrer je pense qu'il faut c'est la clé
ammann est incroyable c'est le cas mais
elle date de quand cette clé 1364 au
moins 1200 64 au moins c'est que ça
servait de brosses à dents aussi non
seulement voilà crétin a non c'est un
retour sous couvre-feu à 23 heures on
rentre à l'hôtel ses trois amis
parisiens admire l'atlantique depuis
deux jours jamais ils n'ont pensé à
annuler leur voyage
sa tâche est pas puisque sa fille en
soirée seront plus calmes
cela devrait plutôt écouté et je veux
bien que vous ne donniez des leçons je
vous connais depuis 30 ans vous fumez
deux paquets de cigarettes par jour
alors vous allez arrêter en sortant de
fumer c'est la même chose
d'abord si c'est la même chose et c'est
votre esprit la responsabilité
individuelle
quand vous n'avez pas de panique paquet
un jour qu'il y passe quelques semaines
il dit mais non c
on vient c'est la responsabilité
collective avoir un bon copain
voilà ce qu'il ya de meilleur
hautmont
m
un bon copain
[Musique]
mais c'est pas une attaque personnelle
zilina ducasse et oui franchement je
paye mon paquet de cigarettes zorro
depuis dix ans oui je ne met personne en
danger
avec ma cigarette ce qui est absolument
pas le cas du virus puisque les devants
vous allez aller à l'hôpital mais je
n'irai pas d euros je m'en payer ça
alors je retire mon attaque ils ont dû
montrer patte blanche
le pass annie terre et une pièce
d'identité sont exigées chaque client
doit fournir une preuve de vaccination
complète depuis au moins 14 jours où un
test négatif de -2 48 heures les videurs
sont intransigeants et les déceptions
nombreuses dans la file d'attenté s'est
habitué à du mal avec ces nouvelles
règles devront dur l'improbable soutien
des télétubbies à la campagne de
vaccination contre le coc vide
les quatre personnages du programme
britannique pour enfants lancé à la fin
des années 90 affichent leur certificat
de vaccination sur les réseaux sociaux
où l'on apprend au passage que tinky
winky dipsy la lie pauvres sont majeurs
et vaccinés donc si même eux ont reçu
leur dose
vous n'avez plus d'excusés peut-on lire
dans les commentaires à l'intérieur pas
de masque et le plaisir de retrouver la
piste de danse pour ceux qui ont pu
rentrer malgré la jauge de 75% et les
restrictions sanitaires
le patron est content de revoir ses
clients un slow langoureux qui commence
qu'à une copine qui me dit t'as vu ton
mari chez willy ou pis alors ils
dansaient qu'une espèce de blondasse
bimbo la la danse et tendrement le slow
up je les regardais j'ai fait a
carrément carrément ème cérémonie des
divorces ont fait la fête pour un
divorce
c'est une tradition ici quand une femme
divorce ses amis et sa famille se
réunisse pour faire la fête
c'est un camion poubelle être que c'est
juste un camion du pas-saint-georges je
pense que la maurienne non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un mal si l'on fait les commerces
et juillet
est ce réaliste et pour que vous êtes
contente que votre fille divorce
je suis très content parce que ma fille
était malheureuse avec son mari mais
aujourd'hui elle est libre à aller taper
sur les tambours applaudissaient et j ai
tiré à l'est
pour quel rôle y est
mais c'est plus
pleurer vous le savez tous le pen
si la flamme olympique brûle pour la
première fois le relais et lui statique
une flamme transmise de porter en porter
sur la même estrade sans jamais
parcourir les rues de tokyo pour éviter
toute éventuelle contamination une image
inédite dans l'histoire olympique mais
rione 15 ans est tout de même fier
d'avoir été choisi
hip hop hip hop hip mois la fierté d'un
pays et de son premier ministre boris
johnson mais aussi de fans étrangers
comme tom cruise qui a téléphoné au
joueur pour les encourager c'est ce que
le football et la sélection représente
pour les femmes dans tout le pays
on est très heureux et on va tout faire
pour les rendre encore plus fier ce soir
lahoud se disait pour être vainqueur il
faut gagner l'italie est championne
d'europe à l'heure où je vous parle pas
des 53 ans et les italiens attendait ce
titre européen est ce que c'est mérité
alain boghossian
les quatre acteurs ont signé pour le
grand frisson casting impeccable
virgin galactic rond l'espace accessible
à tout le monde
16h entrée en scène des super-héros
tapis rouge haie d'honneur 40 minutes
plus tard le vaisseau virgin galactic
quitte la surface de la terre est riche
et largué à quinze mille mètres
d'altitude par son avion-porteur l'avion
spatial unity passe le mur du son en
quelques secondes et grimpe en quelques
minutes il atteint 80 mille mètres
d'altitude seuil officiel de l'espace
selon la nasa
bravo à toi richard et à tes coéquipiers
vous devenez astronautes aujourd'hui
vraiment ce qu'on n'a jamais été dans
l'espace même jamais au dessus de
l'orbité terrestre basse je dirais c'est
l'espace n'existe pas selon j'y crois
parce que vous parler encore de ça
ouais certains cerveaux supporte pas la
vérité mais c'est pas la vérité c'est
une opinion non franchement vous m'avez
gaver à les esprits inférieur et l'on
sait
[Musique]
ce sera pareil à ce
c'est ridicule et heures ce sont des
chercheurs en sociologie de l'université
de cambridge qui on voit la traiter les
données sur la durée du travail de 70000
personnes
oui sachant que voilà ils ont constaté
que le chômage n'était pas bon pour
notre équilibre mais ils sont arrivés à
la conclusion qu'il n'y a pas de
bénéfice pour le bien être moral a
travaillé plus de huit heures par
semaine oui d'ailleurs j'y vais
[Musique]